KENNETH TURAN:
Well, first of all,
thank you Julie,
and thank whoever
was responsible for
inviting me here.
I've driven by this building for
a long time, never been inside.
So thank you for the
opportunity to be inside.
I have a job-- my job is
film critic of the LA Times.
People are always
interested in this job.
I think of it
sometimes as like a job
like working inside
the sewers of Paris.
You know, if you've met
someone on an airplane who
worked in the
sewers of Paris, you
have a lot of
questions for them.
So I want to kind of reverse
the way this usually goes.
I want to talk for a little bit.
But I really want to
devote most of my time
here to answering
questions, because I
think that's what people
are more interested in.
And frankly, that's what
I'm more interested in.
And not only questions
about the book,
just questions about film,
questions about reviewing,
anything that you think I
might have an answer to.
So I'll talk a little bit.
I'll read a tiny
bit from the book.
And then we'll
mostly do questions.
I've seen-- I don't know
how many films I've seen.
But I have a good friend, a
man named David Ansen, who
was for many years a
critic at "Newsweek."
And David, when
he was very small
and started being
interested in film,
he started writing down the
names of every film he saw.
So he has an exact
total of how many films
he's seen in his life.
And he has seen,
at this point, he's
closing in on 10,000 films,
which is a big number.
I don't think I've
seen that many.
But I've seen thousands
and thousands of films.
And most of them are
really forgettable.
Any kind of film, independent
film, foreign language film,
there are forgettable
ones, all those genres.
But I wanted to do a book really
about the films that I love.
I wanted to do essays
about the films that
meant the most to
me, that I really
wanted to maybe take with
me on a desert island.
If the desert island
had a DVD player,
these are the ones
I'd want with me
that I can watch
over and over again.
When I went to college, I took
a course in the New Testament.
I didn't know anything
about the New Testament.
And they told me that
the word gospel--
I hope this is true--
that the word gospel means
the spreading of good
news, that the Gospels were
the spreading of the
good news about Jesus.
And what I want to do
as a critic in general,
but especially with
this book, I want
to spread the good news about
the films that I really love.
I want to share
them with people.
I've already seen them.
I don't get a
percentage of royalties
from them if people watch them.
I just want people to have the
same pleasure from these films
that I've had.
They run the gamut in time from,
I think the earliest one is
1893, is the really
earliest days of film,
a French kind of serial
drama called "Fantomas,"
who was one of the first master
criminals that now have so
taken over popular culture.
This is kind of
where it started.
And I think the last film
in the book is from 2011.
It's an Israeli film
called "Footnote,"
which I really enjoyed.
And they've seen them.
Some of these films,
I've seen quite recently.
Some of these films really
stayed with me since childhood.
I saw a lot of the films--
I'm from New York-- I
saw a lot of the films
as a kid on this program
called "Million Dollar
Movie," that they used
to have in New York that
showed old Hollywood films.
It showed them every
night over and over
again, a couple
times every night.
In fact, the last
time I spoke, someone
told me that his grandmother
was a fan of "Million Dollar
Movie."
Because she could fall asleep
while it was on and then
wake up, and the film would
be showing a second time.
And she could catch
up to what each scene.
So this was a great
way to see films.
The film from
the-- I don't know,
I always, whenever I
talk about in the book,
I think about this--
the first film
I saw that made it into the
book is a film called "I
Am a Fugitive from
a Chain Gang."
This is what I know
now is a pre-code film.
This is an early
sound film from 1932.
It's a period in Hollywood
right after sound came in
and before the production
code was implemented,
where films were
really more daring.
They were a little
crazier and stuff happened
that wouldn't happen in
traditional Hollywood films.
And I'm not going to ruin it
for people who have seen it.
But it's got an amazing ending.
And it's got an ending
that, I can still
remember sitting in
front of the TV as a kid
and seeing this film.
And I was all by myself.
My parents were--
didn't care, you know.
They knew they were
safe with me watching--
I was safe watching
"Million Dollar Movie."
So I'm watching
this film, and it's
got this ending, this
amazingly bleak ending.
And I was just-- I
didn't know what to say.
I still can remember
that feeling,
that I didn't know films
could end like this.
I didn't know it
was legal to end
a film with such a
despairing ending.
So that film-- and now
I know it's pre-code
and I know all about the factors
that went into that ending.
But I still retain the kind
of excitement and energy
of seeing that film then and how
much it really galvanized me.
I said, wow, this
is really amazing.
So each of these films has
that kind of wow factor in it
for me.
And this is, again, an
interesting experience for me.
Usually part of
what I do here is
I'm trying to convince
people to buy the book.
And I don't have to
really do that here,
because you've all
been given the book.
Whoever came up with that
idea, it's a wonderful idea.
But I'm still passionate
about these films
and still hoping that you
will use this book as a way
to watch and enjoy these films.
Some of them will be familiar to
you, some of them will not be.
I think even a
friend who's working
on a similar book,
another critic, who
said that he'd seen
50 of the 54 films.
And I thought he would
have seen everything.
So everyone's going to
have some things they've
seen, some things
they haven't seen.
And I really hope to encourage
people to explore films
that they might not
otherwise have thought of.
And I just want to
read a little tiny bit
from-- I have an essay
at the back called
"The 55th Film," which is
kind of deciding-- it talks
a little bit about the
process about how I came up
with the films on the list.
So I just want to read
a little bit from that.
"I started with an initial list
of more than 100 films compiled
more or less off
the top of my head,
a list I added to after
using reference books
and other compilations to prod
my sometimes stubborn memory.
To be fair to those who've
read my previous collections,
the only stricture I
put on myself was not
to include too many films
from my earlier books,
especially "Never Coming
to A Theater Near You,"
which had some of the
smaller films I really liked.
Rather than come up with
an ironclad list of 54
before I started
to write, I decided
to choose the films as I wrote
about them, one at a time.
I selected these in
no particular order.
When I was ready to begin an
essay, I'd look at my list,
decide which title spoke to me
most strongly, what film I felt
like seeing at that moment
in time, I watch it again,
and begin writing.
What this system did, though I
didn't realize it when I began,
was to give my
inventory of choices
a fluid, quicksilver
quality, making it in my eyes
into an ever-changing,
almost living thing.
While some films were
always going to be there,
others gained or lost
status and momentum
as my mood changed and the
list grew in size and shape.
The closer I got to
finishing, the more difficult,
even excruciating, choosing
the final films became.
Because at this late
stage, picking one film
inevitably meant another title
would be left by the wayside.
By the end, I felt each of the
contending films calling out
to me, pleading with
metaphorical tears in its eyes,
pick me, choose me,
take me with you.
Remember how much
I've meant to you.
Don't leave me behind
in the darkness.
Right up to the
last minute, I was
remembering and
agonizing over new titles
that I had not found room for.
When Peter O'Toole
died, I kicked myself
for leaving "Lawrence of
Arabia" out of the top 54."
And I really do.
I still feel if I had
it to do all over again,
I'd probably kick some film out
and put "Lawrence of Arabia"
in.
I feel bad I left that one out.
"Finally, I broke the
logjam by holding auditions
for the 54th film, watching
half a dozen contenders
before I made my choice.
It was appropriately
enough for a list
compiled in Los Angeles, Roman
Polanski's and Robert Townes'
Chinatown, as good a film
about the city as has
been made that was
my final selection."
OK, so that's kind of about
how the book came about
and why it's important to me.
And again, one of
the things about it
is that the process of picking
these films, especially
since I did it one
by one, it almost
was a process of me finding
out more about myself
or kind of clarifying
things about myself.
I think films, what you like
and what you don't like in film,
really kind of says
something about who
you are on some level.
Looking at these films-- again,
I looked at them all again
before I wrote about them--
I love romantic films.
If I had to pick one film
that was my favorite film,
it's a French film called
"Children of Paradise"
from mid 1940s.
It's just a wonderful romance.
I also like films
about moral dilemmas.
I think those are very dramatic.
I don't find them tedious to do.
Moral choices that people have
to make can be very exciting.
So in some ways, I learned
I think more about myself
than I thought I would.
It's almost like
this book is kind
of-- it's like a spiritual
autobiography, in some ways,
writing this book.
So it was a lot of fun to write.
It was hard carving the
time out to work on it
with all my other stuff,
my other obligations.
But I always felt happy being
able to research, and write
about, and deal with
films that I really loved.
So I hope you have similar
experiences with it.
And I think I'm
ready for questions.
They said you're supposed
to go to the microphone.
So that is it.
OK, let me put on
my seeing glasses,
so that I can see
everyone better.
OK.
AUDIENCE: All right, well
just glancing quickly
through the table
of contents, it
seems like it's heavily weighted
toward earlier films rather
than later ones.
Is that because filmmaking
has gotten less interesting?
KENNETH TURAN: Well,
part of the reason
is that those earlier books I've
written, especially the "Never
Coming to A Theater
Near You," where there's
a lot of more recent
films that I really like.
And again, I didn't want
the book to be the same.
I mean, I do have a
weakness for older films,
but I think if I had not
written that previous book, that
kind of imbalance
wouldn't be there.
I was surprised you
know-- as I say,
I picked these
films one at a time,
and I thought about
them that way.
And it wasn't until I was
completely finished that I
was talking to my
editor, and he said
you have to organize
these films in some way.
So I said, why don't I
break them down by decades
and see what happens.
And I did that,
and I was shocked
to find that there are only
two films from the 1970s
in this book.
This is supposed to be
the great era of film.
And I won't even say
it isn't, but it just
worked out that way.
Chinatown and The Godfather,
which are knockout films,
they're the only two
films from the '70s.
I like those other films,
but for whatever reason,
they don't have the pull for
me that the other films do.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering,
it kind of related
to what he asking, but
in the '40s and '50s,
it looks like you have a whole,
the largest chunk of films.
Is there something about
that period or those films?
What is it that
resonated with you more?
KENNETH TURAN: That's
a good question.
You know, like I
say, I didn't really
think about that until
I looked at the list,
and I said, well, look
at all these films.
Why are they there?
What do I like
about these films?
I think that the '50s
are the biggest chunk.
And again, that was a surprise,
because with the '50s,
it's boring.
It's Eisenhower, country clubs.
What am I doing
celebrating the '50s?
I finally decided that the '50s
had a combination of two things
that I really liked.
Number one, this was still
classical filmmaking.
This was still
classic Hollywood,
and I like old-fashioned films.
I'm not necessarily,
though-- I mean,
I guess there's some films in
here that push the envelope.
I'm not necessarily looking
for films that do that.
So I like classic films.
So this had still the
virtues of the classic films.
But it's post-war.
Everyone came back
from World War II.
Things were bleaker, even though
we were the nominal victors.
People weren't
necessarily happy,
and it was a traumatic time.
I think the combination of that
kind of unsettled bleakness,
that's definitely a
post-war phenomena,
with the classic style
the prewar, that's
what I like about those films.
I think that's
what did it for me.
AUDIENCE: Great, and I
had one other question.
Now we have so many films
that come out these days.
What do you do
when you're looking
at what films you
want to watch now.
Do you have a process?
KENNETH TURAN: That's
a good question.
Yeah, I mean, we
live in the time,
especially-- I think, probably
only in New York and LA--
but definitely New York and LA,
where a dozen films come out
every week, at least,
Week in, week out.
That's a ton of films.
And you know, some films--
Again, I spend a lot of time
reading about films,
talking about films,
reading film magazines,
going to festivals,
talking to people who've
been to festivals,
trying to figure out
which ones are worth it.
And also I hear from publicists.
A lot of these films,
even the tiny ones,
have some kind of publicist.
And they're always sending you
stuff to try and convince you.
But it's a judgment
call on my part
what I think is worth doing.
I look for especially--
I look at trailers a lot.
YouTube has become
a friend of mine.
I look at a lot of
trailers online.
And I can tell largely,
even though I've
been fooled sometimes-- Because
trailer makers cut what they
think the most commercial
trailer will be.
And sometimes, this
commercial trailer,
though it's designed to
get people in the door,
it may not accurately
reflect the film.
So sometimes a film is more
interesting and less commercial
than it looks like
in it's trailer.
But mostly, trailers
really help me not
to tell whether a film
is going to be a success
or anything like
that, but just for me
to know what I want to see.
But I end up seeing
more than I write about.
And it's just trial and error.
I just hope I don't
miss anything good.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
AUDIENCE: If you had to pick
an Alfred Hitchcock film,
which one would it be
to be on your list?
KENNETH TURAN: Well,
there is one on my list.
It's--
AUDIENCE: Oh, I
looked through it.
I didn't see it.
KENNETH TURAN: It's "Vertigo."
AUDIENCE: "Vertigo," OK.
KENNETH TURAN: And
I think "Vertigo"
is a fascinating film
because it's-- Yeah, I mean,
I just think it's
a fascinating film,
because it's-- this
was Alfred Hitchcock,
a very commercial director,
working with two of the biggest
stars of his day, working with
James Stewart and Kim Novak,
big commercial Hollywood film.
And it's an
astonishingly weird film.
It's a very personal film.
It's a film about the kind of
odd things that obsessed him.
I mean, I almost think it's
as personal a film as anything
that you see at Sun
dance, which we're
looking at as personal films.
Everyone says, you
probably know, "Vertigo,"
there was a-- When
"Vertigo" came out-- again,
and this is an interesting thing
about the fallibility or the,
I don't know, the quirkiness of
critics-- when "Vertigo" came
out, I've gone back
and read the reviews,
the critics said,
this is average.
Wait for the next
one, basically.
This is average Hitchcock,
nothing to get excited about.
And as the years went on, people
got more and more interested
in this film.
And "Sight & Sound," the British
film publication, every 10
years, they poll
critics worldwide
about what the
best film ever made
is, which basically
means your favorite film.
And for a decade, "Citizen
Kane" won every 10 years.
And this last time, about two
or three years ago, "Vertigo"
was named by this
worldwide panel of critics
as the best film ever made.
And obviously, nothing is
the best film ever made.
And I don't think "Vertigo" is.
But it fascinates me
that what happened
is that its weird sensibility
caught up with the times.
How weird it was, I think,
kind of put people off
when it first came out.
And now, we kind of like that
as a culture, the strangeness,
the idiosyncrasy, the kind
of obsession that we see.
This resonates with
modern viewers.
So it's a long
answer to "Vertigo."
AUDIENCE: This wasn't
my original question.
But based on what
you just said, so
in the world of very
long Netflix queues
and whatnot, which of these
54 would you say, yes,
if you're going to see
one, that is my favorite.
KENNETH TURAN: Well, it
is "Children of Paradise."
It's a French film.
Has anyone seen
it, show of hands?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, give me
like 4 hours, though.
AUDIENCE: Fair enough.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
it's a long film.
And it was made-- it's an
interesting film, because it
was made at the end
of World War II.
It was made under
the occupation.
difficult circumstances.
Some of the below-the-line
people were Jewish
and they worked from hiding.
You'd never know any of
this as you watch the film.
It's just an interesting
thing to kind of
have in the back of your head.
It's an epic romance.
It's set in Paris in I
think around the 1820s.
It's about one woman and I think
it's four different men, who
become madly in love with her
and how that all works out.
It's just a marvelous film.
And I could really watch
that again and again.
And the other one is
another French film.
Another French
romance, that is, I
have watched again and
again, because it's shorter.
And it's obviously in the book.
It's called "The Earrings of
Madame de--" D-E dot, dot, dot.
It's by a French director--
actually, an Austrian director,
but it's a French
film name, Max Ophuls.
And he was a master
of the moving camera.
Films put on-- in those
days, they weren't hand held;
they were put on tracks.
There are some shots that are
just completely intoxicating,
that I could watch forever.
So I'd put those two
at the top of the list.
AUDIENCE: Wonderful.
Look forward to it.
Let me ask you a
practical question,
if we're using this is
a roadmap for things
to see over the next year or so.
Would you recommend
seeing the movie before--
you don't give away
the ending to--
KENNETH TURAN: I don't
give away the ending.
AUDIENCE: "I'm a Fugitive From
a Chain Gang," for instance.
But do you have any
recommendation of read it
first and then watch it to give
context, or watch and then--
KENNETH TURAN: That's
a good question.
I mean, with my reviews,
people do it both ways,
even though I'm careful in my
reviews not to give away-- I
give away as little of
the plot as possible.
But still some people want
to read them afterwards,
which is fine with me.
You know, I think I
wrote them to encourage
people to see the film.
So maybe reading them
will make you more--
I think in some ways, you
should read them first and see
which ones ring a bell with
you and which ones say,
boy, this one sounds like
something I want to see.
But you could read
it afterwards.
I mean, if you have
enough faith in me
to see it without reading
the essay, then go with god.
AUDIENCE: Sounds good.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: This may or may
not relate to the book,
but I was wondering if
there's a film in the book
or a film in general
that you really
liked but a lot of other
critics didn't like?
If you have an example.
KENNETH TURAN: Yeah, I mean,
I think one that I think of
is one that a lot of
critics-- not a lot,
but there are a lot of lists
of films that people love.
There's kind of a really in
some ways a very standard studio
movie, again a romance, that is
not on a lot of people's list.
It's a film called
"Random Harvest."
It was taken from
a big bestseller.
It stars Greer Garson, and
it has to do with amnesia.
But it's got such
a complicated plot,
even if I wanted to give away
the plot, there's no time.
There's so many things
that happen in it.
And it kind of amazed
me when I saw it,
because the plot was so crazy.
Because so much
stuff happened in it,
because so much good
acting and craft
went into this kind of really
astonishingly far-fetched story
and a very romantic story.
So that's the one I think
that most people would say,
what's that doing there.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
That is easier.
Do you ever feel kind of
like your hands are tied
by your chosen form,
like in the sense of,
I assume that your
criticism, your analysis,
is based on kind of
analysis of the whole film.
And then you have
to do this thing
where you don't tell
anybody what informed,
what you thought.
Because it's like secret
literary analysis.
You're not allowed to tell
people why it did this.
You just have to tell
them that it did this.
Or do you think that it's
kind of freeing to not
have to tell people, this
is why the filmmaker--
KENNETH TURAN: Well, what
I do is speculate on why.
I do actually speculate on why.
I mean, there's no way to know
why, without-- I mean, it's
possible the filmmaker,
him or herself doesn't even
know why they make
the choices they do.
But again, I try and
speculate as to why the--
My job, my goal when I go
in there, I look at the film
and I really want to
say, is it effective?
If it's a comedy, am I laughing?
If it's a documentary,
am I really involved?
If it's a thriller,
am I really nervous
and at the edge of my seat?
And that's my first
line of thought.
And then the second
line of thought
is I do try and figure
out why is this happening?
Why am I feeling the way
the film wants me to feel?
Or why am I not feeling the
way the film wants me to feel?
So I do try and go into that.
But still, I mean it is-- but I
do try, especially because I've
been doing it so long,
I feel like if there
is a film where I can
turn it into an essay
and where I can go
further with things
or look at aspects of the
film, I try and do that.
I don't want to be writing
the same review day after day,
week after week.
So I do look for ways
to make it different.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I have two questions.
My first one I guess relates
to the context of appreciation.
How does, say, watching
a film in movie theater
versus in your personal home
or in a screening studio,
how does that context impact
the way in which you appreciate
or re-appreciate films
as you did in the book?
KENNETH TURAN:
I'm a big believer
in the theatrical experience,
you know this big screen.
I mean, even my screen at
home, I have a projector screen
at home.
It's like a 100-inch screen.
It's quite a big
screen for a home.
I want to be kind of
drawn into the image.
I like being overpowered
by the image.
I mean, I don't want
to watch things small.
I don't enjoy watching
things on my computer.
So I believe that,
in that sense,
the size of the screen and being
in a room where you can really
feel the size of the
screen is very important.
It turns out that it doesn't
really matter to me how big
and-- You know,
the studios often
have this feeling that
they want you surrounded
by people who they think
will like the film.
They want to surround you
with advocates of a film,
so that you will like it.
And it's a fine
theory, but I just
don't think it really works.
I mean, I find that
it doesn't matter
if the audience
likes a film or not.
I have my own
relationship to the film.
I will like it or not like it.
The one thing that
makes a difference
is having a big screen.
I mean, if I see it
on a small screen,
I'm not going to be happy.
I'm not going to get drawn in.
I want to be drawn in.
That's the whole thing
I love about film,
is that they draw you in.
So the big screen
is essential for me.
Audience, recruited audience,
ordinary people, other critics,
doesn't really matter to me.
And you said you had
another question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, my second
question relates to the I
guess your personal interest in
evaluating long form stories,
I guess in the context
of, say, television,
where you have these sort
of multi-season productions
that carry a lot of
filmic qualities.
And then you also
have these sort
of longer form films
that either fit
within the content
of a larger trilogy,
or say a director's
sort of au revoir.
But yeah, what's your
comment on the long form?
KENNETH TURAN: I mean,
they're fascinating.
I mean again, if they're
well done, longer films,
and by extension these
multi-season TV series,
they really draw you in.
They can make
characters more complex.
I think it's exciting what's
being done on television.
I mean, I think the
great thing about TV
is that a lot of the
stuff that people enjoy
are a function of the fact
that television has not
abandoned the adult audience.
And the movies by and
large-- even though they
don't want to admit
it-- the movies
have abandoned the
adult audience.
It just doesn't fit with
their business model.
But with cable, it does fit
with their business model.
And so they're doing this
stuff and it's fascinating.
I don't have time to see
it as much as I'd like to.
I watch this stuff.
I mean, I was binging on
things before it was a word.
You know I would go on vacation
with entire seasons of programs
and just watch for
hours and hours.
So I appreciate
what they're doing.
And it's related to film,
but it's not exactly
the same thing.
There's one film here that I
really like that's quite long.
I think the longest
film in the book
is an Italian film that was
actually made for Italian TV.
It's called "The Best of Youth."
And I think in total, it's about
six hours, if my memory serves.
And it's just totally involving.
It's about the '60s
and two brothers,
and you get incredibly
involved in the story.
So I think the
long formula, they
can do things that shorter
films can't do, for sure.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I also have
a couple questions.
First, you talked
about how introspective
it was as a process of
picking these movies.
And that made me wonder, as a
reviewer, how do you balance
or what side do you choose
between sort of when you write
your review, exposing yourself
and the reaction you had
to the movie versus
putting yourself
in the shoes of your
readers and trying
to guess how they'll react.
KENNETH TURAN: I
think that you really
can't do-- I think of the two
things that you've mentioned,
you can only do one thing.
You can only be yourself.
I think criticism is an
intensely personal job.
What you like and
what you dislike,
comes a lot out of the
kind of person you are,
what's important to you,
just the kind of things
you personally like.
If someone said to
me, put yourself
in the shoes of all the readers,
I wouldn't know where to begin.
I just embrace the fact
that this is personal,
that there's not-- I write
for myself, for people
like me, for people who I think
are intelligent and interested.
There's no way for
me to write kind
of for an audience
that isn't me.
I don't think I could do it.
AUDIENCE: My other
question was you
talked about how
one of the things
you sort of measure as
you watch a movie is
how well the movie is
at being what it is,
like in a comedy
making you laugh,
and in a thriller
thrilling, and so on.
I mean, you also talked about
how trailers can kind of be
a little bit deceiving,
because they focus
on the commercial
parts or what would
be commercially successful.
And so I was
wondering if there's
a film that particularly
delighted to you
in a way that you
didn't expect going in,
maybe something you thought
was a comedy that thrilled you
or vice versa?
KENNETH TURAN: Huh,
That's a good question.
I mean, good films--
there's a film
that I saw years ago called--
not "Sunset Boulevard"
but a filmed called
"Hollywood Boulevard."
It was a Roger Corman film made
by a man named Allan Arkush.
It was about a mythical
studio in Hollywood
called "Miracle Pictures."
And their motto was, if it's a
good picture, it's a miracle.
And sometimes, I feel that way.
I mean, really the films
that really work the best,
they do all astonish you.
I mean, it's so hard to
make a really good film.
I think one that I think of that
was a real surprise to me there
was at Cannes,
there was one night
I remember just going
into a screening.
I was really tired
and irritable.
And the film was
about childhood.
And I'm not necessarily a big
fan of films about childhood.
And I thought, oh boy,
I'm sorry I'm here.
And the film came on, and it
just absolutely took me away.
It transported me.
It's, in fact, in the book.
It's a French Canadian
film called "Leolo,"
which is one of the more
obscure films in the book.
So Yeah, I mean, it's
wonderful to be excited.
I mean, that's why I do this,
is to have those moments to walk
in and say, oh my god,
this is so excited.
And again, I write
to try and get
more people to have
that experience.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'll try a slightly
different tack on this.
Do you have any
films that you felt
kind of had a lot of
potential but just missed it,
that if they had just
done things a little bit
differently, they could
have been great films
but sort of missed the mark?
KENNETH TURAN: Yeah, I feel
that all the time actually.
I mean, those films obviously
are not in the book,
because the one's that are there
are the ones that I feel really
did live up to it.
But I think one of the
things about being a critic
is that people want you-- people
come up to me all the time
and talk to me about films.
Or when they've written, I hear
from them about my reviews.
People want you to either
love a film or hate a film.
They want it to be I guess maybe
the word is binary that way.
They want you to either
say, I love this film,
you have to go see it, or this
is the world's worst film,
stay away under all costs.
A lot of films
fit in the middle.
They are the kind of films
that you described, that there
are good elements to
them, but they just
haven't gone quite far
enough, or some things
don't quite, quite gel.
And it's hard to write
about those films.
And I think in some ways,
it's frustrating to readers,
because they have to figure
out, well, do I see it.
And I try and give help in that.
There's a film that
came out I think a week
or so ago called "The
Drop," which I thought
was very-- had a lot of really
good elements in it, especially
James Gandolfini.
It was his final role.
But it's a film set
in Brooklyn with a lot
of European-- really, really
good European actors putting
on Brooklyn accents.
And I'm from Brooklyn, and
I was sensitive to that.
So I thought it just
kind of was a near miss.
There's a lot of near misses.
I mean, they're better
than the terrible films.
But I just wish they
were all better.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First question,
when I first went
to a film festival many years
ago, I was so enthusiastic.
I went through the program
and circled all the things
that I'm going to see.
I was like talk about binging.
And then I realized that
after seeing two films
in a row, the third
one, I would just
sit there and go
completely over my head.
And I'm just kind of wondering
your I mean what's the highest
frequency that you can
watch that's-- yeah,
let's leave at that.
KENNETH TURAN:
No, I mean, that's
a very interesting question.
In fact, I mean film festivals,
for the reasons you state,
are really bad
places to see films,
because you get overload.
For professional reasons, when
I go to-- I think at this point,
basically, I go to Sundance
and I go to Cannes.
And you know, I look in
on multiple films a day,
two, three, four films
are day, sometimes five.
I don't see them all the
way through necessarily.
I can't, past one or two films--
Anything I see at a festival,
I have to see again before
I write about it at length,
just for the reason
you're talking about.
You get kind of overload.
You can't really--
at least for me,
I can't take them in on the
level of focus and intensity
I need to, to write
about them, if it's
the third or fourth
film of the day.
So one of the
frustrations of festivals
is anything I see there, if
I have to write a full scale
review later, I'm going to
have to see it all over again.
It's just, I have exactly
the same experience you do.
I mean, your mind
just won't take them
in the way they took in the
first one or the second one.
AUDIENCE: Unlike TV series,
which I did binge on.
And that actually goes very
well, because it's one world.
You don't have to like take
on all these different worlds.
KENNETH TURAN: Yeah, you've got
to totally reboot your head,
somewhere else, totally
different kind of film.
And you just get tired.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, so when you
want to see-- like let's say
a movie is coming out that
you're really excited to see--
it's either by a
director who you love
or about a subject
matter that you like--
and as interested
as you are in it,
you can tell it kind
of missed the mark.
How do you write a fair
review and criticism of that?
KENNETH TURAN: Well,
those are sad moments,
because you want-- especially
if you're excited by the notion.
I always am thinking--
even though maybe something
I said earlier will sound
different-- I'm always
thinking about I write
for your readers.
I have to be honest.
That's all I have.
People trust me to be honest.
They may disagree
with me, but I have
to be telling the truth
as far as I can see it.
And even though it's very sad
to have to write a disappointed
review about something I
was looking forward to,
I have to do it.
As I said, people come
up to me all the time
and ask me what I
think about films.
And sometimes, people
come up to me--
My nightmare is when
someone comes up to me--
and it happens--
and they say, I went
to-- fill in the blank--
I went to this film
just because you liked
it and I hated it.
And then they look
at me and they say,
did you really like that film?
And I want to be
able to say yes.
I don't want to be thinking,
you know I cut it a break
because I like
the director, or I
cut it a break because I
like the subject matter.
I want to be able to say,
no, I really liked it.
So I worry about that,
but finally, I just
have to be as honest as I can.
Otherwise, there's no
point in doing just.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was
curious how important
pleasure or entertainment
is in your reception
or your appreciation of a film.
Like how much can you
accommodate difficulty
in watching a film?
There are some
certain critics who
are almost connoisseurs
of difficulty, right?
And you think when you watch
something like "Barry Lyndon"
or maybe like a long
form Terrence Malick
film or something where you
could actually potentially
be bored for
stretches at the film
but you really appreciate
the craft of it.
How important is that?
I read some critics,
and it's all
about the pleasure and the
excitement of watching.
And they don't like as much the
sort of difficult stretches.
But how much do you
appreciate the level
of craft versus
personal pleasure?
KENNETH TURAN: That's
an interesting question.
I think they all kind of
meld together on some level.
I mean, I have to find
something to appreciate
if I'm going to appreciate it.
I can appreciate
something that doesn't
sound likeable or something
that can be difficult.
I mean, I saw a film a few
weeks ago called "Starred Up."
It's a British film.
It's an exceptionally
violent film,
which is usually
something I don't like.
So I kind of winced at
the violent parts of it.
But the filmmaking
was so exciting,
and the storytelling
was so good,
and the acting was
so good, that I said,
I really like this film.
So I mean, pleasure is kind
of a malleable quality.
Sometimes, you find
yourself liking
things because of the skill
involved that you would not
think you would like.
I mean, sometimes
films that sound boring
or that you even think
you'd be bored by, end up
being fascinating.
But I mean, I guess it all
comes back to pleasure for me
I think.
But that doesn't just mean
that things are easy and happy.
Sometimes very
difficult films can
be a pleasurable experience,
if the person making them
is really gifted and you
really get on that wavelength.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, no,
I think it does.
I mean, on the
other hand, can you
think of any films that are
like just big sprawling messes?
KENNETH TURAN: There's a
lot of big sprawling messes.
AUDIENCE: No, that are
at the level of craft
are not like the
best films ever made
but you love them for that
incoherence or that uniqueness?
KENNETH TURAN: Yeah,
that's a good-- Probably,
sometimes films
just take you away.
I mean, I really enjoy it.
Again, it's a film I had
written the last-- About six
months ago, I wrote a review
of "Captain America," where
I wrote about "Marvel" fatigue.
I said, you know, I've just
seen enough "Marvel" movies.
They're all the same.
They're all kind of
machine-made and I've had it.
And the next "Marvel"
film I had a look at
was "Guardians of
the Galaxy," which
is this kind of big messy
film, and a lot of critics
have written that it
doesn't really make sense.
But I enjoyed it.
It had a spirit and a
kind of an energy that
really captivated me.
So I mean, each film
is a unique experience.
Again, that goes
back to why I can't
see two or three, more than
two or three on the same day.
You want to be taken where
the film wants to take you.
You want to be open and
receptive to what it's doing.
And if it's a mess
but an enjoyable mess,
I'm OK with that.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Since it worked
with our last question,
I'll share another experience.
I had the extraordinary luck of
watching "Heavenly Creatures"
without knowing anything
about it-- what it was about.
So I had this like--
this will probably
make it right at
the top of my list
very easily just because there
was this moment in the film,
there's this realization,
oh my god, they are serious.
This is not a fantasy.
They're actually going to kill
the mother, which-- I'm sorry.
KENNETH TURAN: Don't
give away the end.
AUDIENCE: So sorry.
KENNETH TURAN: See, people
don't like it when you--
AUDIENCE: I'm not saying
if they did or didn't.
I'm just saying that
they were going to.
And maybe five
years or six years
after I saw it in
a movie theater,
I saw that it was coming on TV.
And I said, great.
I was going to watch it.
And it turns out
that, I remembered
the ending all wrong.
Like I somehow managed
to change my memory
as I was kind of going over
it and thinking about it over
and over.
I'm just wondering if you had
that experience with a movie
that you haven't
seen in a long time?
KENNETH TURAN:
Well, I mean I did
have with this book-- As I said,
I didn't want to put anything
in here that I didn't
really still like,
so I looked at everything again.
And not that I remember
them differently,
but sometimes, there
were some films
that I had loved when they
came out that I thought
would be in the book
that didn't make it.
Because I saw them again,
and I said, you know,
I just don't like them as--
You know, what I used to think
was a wonderful Cuban film,
I still enjoyed it a lot, but
it wasn't one of my favorites,
a film called "Lucia," a very
long, three-part Cuban film
that I really liked.
But it wasn't as strong
as I remembered it.
It wasn't strong enough
to make the top 54.
So sometimes, you do remember.
Again, this is
all very personal.
You're a different person
years later sometimes.
Everything changes.
AUDIENCE: My question
is about old movies.
At this point of your
career, do you still
discover old movies new to you?
Like for me, I like old
movies, but this summer I
was on a flight on
British Airways.
And I just played on the
entertainment system,
I saw the movie
"Summertime" from the 1950s
with Katharine Hepburn in it.
And I really enjoyed it.
But my way used to try
to find some old movies
is like this book that lists.
But I never remember seeing
that movie on any of the lists.
So what else can I do to kind
of find this kind of old movies?
Because there's no trailers
showing where I go to--
KENNETH TURAN: No, that's true.
That's true.
Yeah, I mean, I still--
there's so many.
I mean, my worry is not having
the time to see all the films
that I haven't
seen, not that I'm
going to run out of ones to see.
There are always old films.
Now, I'm not talking
about new films.
I'm talking about the old films.
Hollywood used to put out way
more films than they do now.
I think in 1939,
which is considered
to be the top year and the
golden age of Hollywood--
I was just looking
at something, and I
think they said they were--
I can't remember how many,
but there may be as many as 600
films came out in that year.
There were a lot of studios,
and there were these poverty row
studios that also
turned out films.
So there's a ton of stuff
out there to be discovered.
Like I said, this book not
only are there 54 films,
there's a second 54.
And there's also each
film has a notation
at the end of what
to watch next.
So if you like one
of the films in there
and you want to see
something else like it.
I mean, there are lists online.
I mean also you can look at what
companies like Criterion, which
is probably the gold standard
of re-releasing stuff,
they are always finding
new exciting directors.
Actually, I just got
an email from them.
They're having-- And also,
there's a lot of directors
overseas that you can
see their old films.
They're putting out-- I can't
remember the gentleman's name--
but there's a Japanese
director from the '50s
that I'd never heard of
that they're putting out
a box set of five of his films.
So that's very exciting.
There's all kinds
of stuff out there.
I think you just have
to do-- research online,
I think is probably
the best way.
But you're not going to run out.
There's a ton of
stuff out there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: OK, I guess
I'm curious are there
particular movies that you've
reviewed where you've gotten
a lot of like flack or blowback?
Do you have any stories
about that in particular?
KENNETH TURAN: There's one
that comes immediately to mind.
I wrote several
times, more than once,
I was not a fan of "Titanic."
And I wrote several
negative pieces about it.
And James Cameron wrote
a long open letter
to "The Times," which
"The Times" published,
demanding that I be fired.
This really happened.
And so that was probably
the strongest blowback
I've ever had.
But even before that, I
mean that was still the film
that I've gotten the most mail
about, both pro and con, people
who love the film and people
who didn't love the film.
And with email, I get
more stuff than ever.
So it happens.
AUDIENCE: For what
it's worth, I was
glad you wrote the critical
review of that film.
KENNETH TURAN: Well, good.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So how
do you normalize
for kind of buzz or hype?
I mean, I know for
instance like you
said you didn't write your
review of "Boyhood" initially,
because there was so much love
and you weren't as blown away
by it as everybody else.
And for instance,
for me, I saw both
"Gravity" and "Guardians
of the Galaxy,"
what I consider to be peak buzz.
But a couple weeks
after they came out,
everyone is saying
how amazing they were,
and I was just kind of-- I
went in expecting a miracle
and, I was like, OK, it
was a good movie, whatever.
So how do you, as a
critic, try to neutralize
the effect of that kind of--
KENNETH TURAN: No,
that's a good question.
I know exactly what
you're talking about.
I mean, what I try and
do is avoid that stuff
as much as possible.
I don't talk to people.
I don't read stuff.
I leave rooms when
conversations are going on.
I want to go into the
film as cold as possible.
I don't want to feel that
I'm reacting to the hype.
I want to react to the film.
So I try and avoid knowing
about the hype as much as I can.
And also sometimes, studios
are sensitive to that.
And they will show
the film to me early.
Even if it's at a
festival, sometimes I
can see a film here
in LA so that I
can have an honest
experience and not
be reacting to
what everyone said.
But with these big
films, it is a problem.
And the way I can do it
is to try-- Publicists
are always wanting to
talk to you about films
and tell you about their films.
And I don't want to-- I
just want to see the film.
And someone wanted to tell me
about, it wasn't even her film.
It was another film
that she'd really liked.
And I remember like I was in a
garage trying to get to my car.
And I literally, I
ran away from her.
I just said, I don't
want to hear it.
But I think what you're talking
about for me is a real factor.
And I really try-- I
try to know as little as
possible about a film going in.
And that can be difficult,
but that's really my goal.
AUDIENCE: So the
only thing I really
know about reviews is that
they come out on Fridays
or maybe a little bit earlier.
How long does it take
you to write a review?
What is the turn?
Or is their deadline?
KENNETH TURAN: Oh, yes.
There's always a deadline.
For sure, there's a deadline.
Yeah, my reviews they want--
they do come out on Friday.
Again, the presence
of the online world
has changed things
somewhat, because we
have a lot of readers online
and they get the review earlier.
My understanding is
that the reviews go up
online sometime on Thursday.
So they need it from me, they
want it from me on Wednesday.
And you know how long
it takes is partly
a function of how much time
the movie itself gives me.
In other words,
sometimes the studios
are nervous about a film and
they won't show it to you
until the last minute.
Sometimes if a review
is due Wednesday,
I won't see until Tuesday night.
Sometimes I'll see it Wednesday
morning; I mean, this is rare.
Sometimes, they
won't show it at all.
But if a film is good
and they show it to me
with plenty of
time-- I mean, I like
to have a certain amount
of time, I don't know,
ideally at least a week to
just let it sit in my mind.
This is a week when
I don't do anything.
When I'm just walking
around living my life
and I'm thinking about the film.
At odd random moments,
it'll pop into my mind,
and I'll get an idea
about what I'm thinking.
So after it does that for
about a week, then I sit down
and I usually do it
in a day, two days,
depending on the film,
what else is going on.
I type up my notes.
I take a lot of notes.
Critics don't always take notes.
Some of my friends,
who are critics,
write almost nothing down.
And they are able to retain it.
But I have to take notes.
So I take a lot of notes.
I type them up, which
gives me an idea
where my thoughts are going.
Because when I see
overall what I've
been saying, as I just take
notes moment to moment.
And when I type them up, I get
a sense of what I'm thinking.
And then I sit
down with the notes
and I put together the review.
And like I say,
the whole process
takes one to two
days for a film.
AUDIENCE: And then
one other thing
is do you have time to watch
good television or YouTube
videos?
KENNETH TURAN: Not as much.
Well, sometimes when I'm
trying to waste time,
I'll see what's on YouTube.
Writers are always
wanting to waste time.
And again, with the television,
I don't have the time.
That's why I just said, I binge.
I take the stuff on
vacation with me.
I have too heavy a
screening schedule
to really be able to watch
something on a regular basis.
So if say, something my
friends tell me is good,
I will get the
whole season on DVD
and take it with me on vacation.
And there is great
stuff on television.
I just don't have
the time to watch it.
AUDIENCE: Got it.
Thanks.
KENNETH TURAN: OK, one
more, last question.
AUDIENCE: OK, this
is actually more
a little bit of a
technical question.
But some of the films that
are recommended on these lists
are a little bit obscure.
And do you have any tips on
how or where to find them?
KENNETH TURAN: Most,
I think-- In my book,
I think just about
everything is available.
Even though they sound
obscure, and they are obscure,
they're basically all there.
I think the only thing
that really isn't there
in any findable form, believe it
or not, is a 1920s silent short
by a man named Max Davidson,
that the copy I have
is a European DVD that
won't play on American--
I've got a multi-region
DVD player.
But everything else in the
book is available, certainly
for DVD rental or purchase
and probably for download.
There's more out
there than you think.
They're there.
AUDIENCE: Let's all
thank Kenneth Turan
for joining us today.
KENNETH TURAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]